welcome you can ask about restaurants  museums and hotels in four cities in the  orlando area can I see the Chinese  restaurants in orlando there are 19  chinese restaurants in orlando summer on  east colonial drive south kirkman road  and west colonial drive can I get the  phone number for tasty wok the phone  number of tasty wok is area code 407 896  89 88 without y'all ding tai fung yo  secret language are looking careful see  jump at dojo he go yamaha jumpin ciaccio  Sultan Hamid Auto Show tantrum shot hola  chinito jeongshik yellow dye solution 13  Typhon yoshimoto cert imma king tide  from the job packs hi yourself oh I'm  talkin [ __ ] shock went well hung  symphony you go